a blm rider was killed over the weekend
how and why was he killed well he showed
up to
one of these riots they're still
happening around the country where
people are shutting down major
intersections
mobbing up on cars right coming up and
attacking people
he shows up to one of these with an
ak-47
not even an ar-15 some people don't know
the difference between these things the
ar-15 is based
off of western rifles
and the ak-47 is based off of like
soviet rifles that you see more
in the middle east and in russia she's
got that's the one with that kind of
bendy magazine
so the he shows up with this ak-47
then a group of people including him
mob a car and start attacking the car
and then some bullets ring out and it is
being disputed who fired first and what
exactly happened
take a listen
you see people just totally taking over
the street walking everywhere
i can't really see quite where those
bullets are coming from
cameraman drops to the floor
[Music]
let's back up you see some more there's
more in exchange of fire
where are we where are we is the are we
in fallujah
are we living in the middle east or
something why is this happening on our
streets
why even before the bullets rang out why
are hordes of people allowed
to shut down whole streets and
intersections
in the first place why is that being
permitted and what what exactly happened
here
well we can at least see from
photographs
that there's a mob of people
that starts mobbing up on a car starts
banging on the car starts attacking the
car
and this guy garrett foster
has the ak-47 and he's got it pointed at
the car now it's being disputed was he
pointing it at the driver in the car or
just at the car
i think that's a little besides the
point here
then the driver in the car i guess had a
gun on him as well
and the question is who fired first and
who returned fire
the family of garrett foster are saying
that
he did not fire first at all he he did
not discharge his weapon
there was a police press conference last
night
that said that the according to the
driver
the gunman garrett foster pointed the
gun
at him in his car and so he discharged
his gun pulled away and then another
protester
fired who really knows here's what i
know
if a driver is in a car and he's got a
gun because it's texas
and you know and if this by the way were
earlier america people would be armed
much more regular than they are than
they are today
the left now wants to disarm everybody
particularly the guns that garrett
foster was using
but because the narrative is flipped now
because it's politically convenient for
them to support this guy with the gun
all of a sudden they've dropped all of
their gun control arguments
we know that there was a guy in a car
with a gun we know that there was a
mob of anarchists that had been taken
over our streets
for the last many weeks we know that one
of these rioters
had an ak-47 and it was not
just strapped behind him or something
like that we've seen him
holding the gun and it was pointed
somewhere in the vicinity
of this driver at the car maybe not
quite at the driver
but somewhere there if you are in that
situation
and you've got a mob attacking your car
and one of those guys
has an ak-47 and that ak-47 is pointed
at your car
you are 1000 percent within your rights
to defend yourself to defend your
property for one
but also to defend yourself because
guess what's going to happen
if they get you out of that car nothing
good
nothing good is going to happen driver
from
every piece of evidence that we have
right now completely justified in fact
we even have that the media gaslighting
on this is so outrageous
that they're trying to cover up these
videos we have video of the guy of the
demonstrator demonstrator was killed
discussing why he brought the ak-47
in graphic language tell us a little bit
about the gun again
oh it's uh ak-47 uh what you got it out
tonight they don't let us march in the
streets anymore so gotta practice some
some of all right
[Music]
do you feel like you'll need to use it
no
i think the uh i mean if i use it
against the cops i'm dead
i think all the people that hate us and
you know want to say to us
are you too big of uh to stop and
actually
do anything about it
our roommate got arrested and they
stopped letting us march anywhere so
start caring so he's got the gun
strapped across his front not across his
back he's got it strapped across his
front
and he says yeah i've got this out here
because i think the people that want to
stop
us from taking over the streets and
bullying and intimidating them
and and disobeying the law i think the
people who want to stop us
they're two big wusses i'll say wusses
he used a more colorful word
wusses to actually do anything about it
this is aggressive language
this is threatening language and of
course he's got a
mask over his face ostensibly for covid
although you know
all of the antifa guys have had masks
over their face forever
and he's got the ak in front of him
it's not a good situation to be in and
by the way the people who are
encouraging these riots
are in part culpable for this guy's
death
he look he's don't take your guns to
town son leave your guns at home boy
don't take your guns to town
is uh some age-old advice in american
life
but if you're going to go there you're
going to have it out you're going to be
in a provocative situation
and you're going to be with a group
that's attacking a car and you're going
to maybe have appointed
at the car and then you're putting
yourself in an impossible situation
that's not the narrative that the media
are going to push to you they're going
to throw out everything they've ever
believed about guns
and police and protesting rather
but it just imagine for a sec i guess
this is this is how you can tell
what the real story is imagine that that
guy garrett foster were a member of the
tea party
it's impossible too because the tea
party was the best behaved political
movement
probably in the history of our country
but imagine that guy were in the tea
party
and you had a tea party guy show up with
an ar-15
and he's out there and they're mobbing
cars and let's say it were cars of
democrats you know or people of color
or women i don't know whatever whatever
you know identity group
the left is going to use and then that
person defended themselves
do you really think the media would be
would be upset about that
no they would be they would be
celebrating
that someone defended themselves against
these presumably racist
terrible no-good awful they're like
nazis in the streets
these protesters that's what you would
hear if it were the tea party
but because it's the left they throw
everything everything out of the window
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts